love this man's perspective which is why
he's in the pro football hall of fame
um for his work uh writing and covering
the sport for decades and
having him on now that the super bowl 55
matchup is set
between the bucks and chiefs brady
and mahomes peter king from football
morning in america and nbc sports our
colleague from nbc sports how are you pk
hey rich i'm getting ready for brady
mahomes five
an amazing two to two so far wow mahomes
121 points
brady 120. that's insane i have a
feeling this might be a good one
i i i still can't it's still brady's
numbers are ridiculous i mean you
it looks like a typo anytime i read it
in
say your column or on a topic bar as we
use the phrase
uh on nfl game day morning it's insane
there are no numbers and the
conversation is who's the greatest
is over it doesn't matter if brady wins
two sundays from now peter it's over of
course but
but i think i think just uh you know
like i i talked to him last night he was
on the bus
on the way from lambeau to austin
strobel airport in green bay
i'm so sick i know the names of the
airports that's you man
in these towns including who the
airports are named after
it's austin strobel international
airport in green bay
it's about a 10 to 12 minute ride from
lambeau
so anyway last night i said to him
you were going to your 10th super bowl
no other quarterback has been to more
than
five you know two two years ago after
the game in kansas city you said this is
crazy it's insane it's uh you know it's
it's ridiculous
okay i said so what about now and he
goes i know i know and
and then rich there was this pause of
six seconds
i i ended up timing it there's this
pause
and i almost said to him hey are you
there
hello we're here and it was just he had
no idea what to say
yes you know it was he just he
i i mean i he could have been faulkner
or hemingway
i don't know how you put into words what
the heck is going on here other than
you know as i wrote today i mean look as
as incredible as michael jordan was
he went to six finals in 15 years
and and and gretzky went to six stanley
cup finals in 20 years
this guy's been to 10 super bowls
in 19 years i i don't know
i i just i mean you know it's it's hard
to
really is hard to put into words and
then it's the first ever matchup between
two winning the the quarterbacks who won
the two previous super bowls we've never
seen that in the super bowl
that's never happened super bowl 55 will
be the winners of super bowl 53 versus
the winner of super bowl 54 we've never
seen anything like that
we've never seen a quarterback uh take
the field in his home stadium for a
super bowl
and um we've we've never seen a chief
quarterback play like mahomes
we've never we you could make a case
that you know obviously brady won
back-to-back super bowls in years four
and five when he was
um in in in the nfl after
pretty much sitting his first year two
mahomes is kind of
the only guy who could ever catch brady
and he's got the coach who's not going
anywhere
you know like there's that too that that
brady could
kind of derail this you know what he
wrote to me somebody wrote me an email
this weekend and said hey
you know you say we're never going to
see that again in our lifetimes when i
said that brady
in 14 conference championship games i
just
i don't think we'll ever see it and my
point
to him was okay i i mean certainly
patrick mahomes is off to a fantastic
start
okay now all he has to do is get to 11
of them in the next 15 years
you know so he and and you know what he
might
i'm not saying that it can't happen i'm
saying that i do not think we're ever
going to see this again
and as great as i think mahomes is and
rich you know what
his full personality was absolutely
totally and and the way he is as a
person was absolutely totally on display
in that
in that call with you you know about
about his nickname because he is
a guy it's like tyron matthews said to
me last night he's the
the ultimate perfect leader for a team
it is
never about him he's a little bit
uncomfortable now
he doesn't want to say hey rich i hate
that nickname it stinks
but so he just says hey you know i i
don't really want any gamer
you know and and and so what
and again i am not saying these two
things are similar
you know what impressed me the most
about the chiefs yesterday the absolute
most and obviously
we take for granted the greatness of
tyreek hill and kelsey
and mahomes but i'll tell you what
really impressed me the most
okay uh machole hardman muffs that pun
and hands buffalo a nine nothing lead
and you're thinking
man this is this might be
a game and buffalo might be able to do
this
and then what happens on the next long
drive by the chiefs
second play of the drive first down
conversion pass
mahomes to hardman uh and then
the last play of the drive a touchdown
pass
from uh from mahomes to hardman
and i just kept thinking to myself don't
you
want your leader your great guy there's
a lot of guys who are going to go up to
hardman on the bench and say hey don't
worry about it man don't worry
and you saw it you know tv showed
dave tobe the uh special teams coach and
and andy reed went up to a bunch of
players went up to him
mahomes put some action behind
his words he didn't have to say hey i'm
still coming to you
it really reminded me of when david
tyree
before the super bowl against the
patriots 13 years ago
when david tyree dropped five balls at
practice
they get back to the hotel two days
before uh
playing the 18-0 patriots and eli
manning says to him
i'm coming to you on sunday and it
wasn't just words
he came to him on sunday he threw a
touchdown pass to tyree in the fourth
quarter
and then he threw the helmet catch to
tyree and so
that to me is what a leader does peter
king here on the rich eyes and shown
coaches too
the enemy and uh and reed dialing up the
plays too including flipping one two
hardman on an end around and he took a
damn near to the house as well i mean
it's i again the fact that it's reid and
b enemy
and aryans and leftwich you know two old
school coaches
with younger uh assistants dialing up
the plays
former players leader of men um
i i i'm look it's an amazing matchup and
we're going to have two weeks to dissect
it i do want to spend the final moments
here with you
to talk about not only the aftermath uh
in green bay but some of the other
stories including matthew stafford is
now available and watson is rumored to
be on the run
and and it's entirely pop and on that
front
is it at all possible that aaron rodgers
really is going to have the hard
feelings that he
clearly had on display yesterday whether
it was
something we don't know about the
iceberg we're just seeing the tip from
the draft
that he said wasn't much of anything all
year long and he puts together an mvp
campaign
um isn't it possible that the hard
feelings that he definitely
expressed yesterday in a fit of
depression potentially an
and an awful gutting loss
can actually linger and that this is a
possibility that he
is up in the air but they might they
might but
there's a few different things in play
here
aaron rodgers has three years left on
his contract
you know brian guticans has shown that
he's got a lot of ted thompson in him
you know we're not we're not do we're
not like
you know when they decided to move on
from farv in 2008
uh he didn't care about the public
pressure and he didn't care about the
pressure from farp
you know he made aaron rodgers his
quarterback and i mean it's a different
story obviously but
brian goodakins is just going to say hey
listen let's give this a month
everybody just calm down of course
everyone's gonna be gutted after an
emotional game like this
but i also will just this occurred to me
after listening to rogers last night
first of all over the years over 37
years
and 40 years really covering sports of
all kinds
it's always better to get real feelings
talking to players very soon after the
game
okay that obviously you're going i think
if you talk to aaron rodgers on thursday
of this week
you'd probably get a different view not
not as
gloomy of you from rogers life happens
sometimes you lose games but
i'll also remind you that wasn't it just
a week ago
when they had this great game against
the rams against this great rams defense
that he said it's and i'm paraphrasing i
don't remember exactly what he said but
it's something like
it's the honor of my lifetime to be the
quarterback of this team
i love this team all that and now all of
a sudden he's dropping hints
that uh maybe we ought to think about my
future and again
i don't even know what he said yesterday
other than i'm really depressed that we
lost this well
he said that you should see what the
future holds no he said that that
that people's futures um are up in the
air
including mine those are the words that
he used
of course he did but does that mean that
he he personally believes that
he'd be better off somewhere else no he
didn't say that
i mean i think the the proverbial we
on people's futures are up in the air
including me
of course he's going to say that he's
whatever he is 38 years old
uh who knows how much they're 38 this
year i think right
uh who knows how much longer he's going
to play but all i can say is this he
just had an mvp season
he's going to win the mvp why the
packers would think of trading him now
maybe he pulls a i want out i'm not
going to play in like carson palmer
and maybe he pulls that i don't know he
could do whatever he wants but
it sure seems like life changed with one
loss in one week
and i would also say this rich you know
aaron rodgers was not faultless on that
last drive
at all on third and goal from the eighth
he should have run the ball into the end
zone
and and a two point conversion ties and
and whatever
i mean you know look at the throw he
made to devonta adams at the goal line
on that play
look at watch it how in the world do you
make that throw
well it's a scrum of people and he
throws a ground ball at devonta adams
when
he's got a wide open pasture in front of
him would he absolutely have made it i
don't know
but he's got a heck of a lot better
chance of of running that ball in
than in trying to laser a throw into the
ground to devonte adams well let's
discuss this a little bit peter king
here
on the rich eisen show um that yeah
of course there's blame to go around
everywhere um
the two brady picks were turned into
zero points you can't and
you keep allowing brady an opportunity
to
beat you he will certainly when he's
playing at such a high level
like this which is makes it all the more
bizarre
that you would hand the ball off to him
with a five-point lead hoping to get it
back
that you that you hoped that you would
get one more shot from the eight-yard
line
thanks to your defense that that that
and and and
you know that's the decision that
ultimately matt lafleur made
i will make a decision to get my defense
to give my guy
the ball back rather than put it in the
hands of my mvp
and i think that's why rogers was
potentially very angry at the end of the
game because it's writ large
that here i am back in the nfc hold on a
second here i am back in the nfc
championship game peter
and we lose again um and you drafted my
replacement instead of somebody that
could have helped me in a game
like this and and one last thing
and i think his and i'm going to talk
about this later as well get into it
i think his fit of peak with his coach
was
obvious when he said the reason why i
didn't run it and threw it to devonta
adams is because i thought i had one
more
down left when running it would have
been the indication that he thought he
had another down left because wouldn't
you rather if you're stopped on fourth
and two
get those six yards with your legs that
you clearly could get
clearly him saying i thought i had
another down left which is why i throw
it
is throwing his coach a little wee bit
under
the 12 bus right there and i think his
coach deserved it
i'm not saying it was unwarranted but i
i think that that
that's what i how i interpreted roger's
comments yesterday if he
if he thought he had another down he
should run it i i agree i agree
i'm not i'm not arguing with you about
i'm sorry this is my new york way of
raising my voice
he should have aaron rodgers should have
had
another down it is totally fruitless
to kick a field goal you still need a
touchdown
why are you kicking a field goal
it's a dumb call by matt lafleur
okay but but be that as it may be that
as it may
aaron rodgers is not faultless on the
last drive of the game
on third down wouldn't you if you
thought you had four down
if you thought you had four down you'd
run it
and you could get and you could get five
six seven yards with your legs
wouldn't you rather have fourth and goal
from the one and a half
than from the eight i would you have an
incredible but you have much more that
you can do
so so again rich i agree
he should have had that fourth down and
and and look brian gouda kunst i said it
on draft weekend
it's insane that the green bay packers
didn't draft
a wide receiver in the draft last year
okay drafting a running back at the end
of the second round i i just
um i'm mind boggled however however
aaron rodgers the whole year has been a
don't worry be happy guy we're going to
cope with this everything's gonna be
okay
it's like one series of downs
made all the happy stuff that he talked
about all through the off season it
seems to me
seems to me made all that really
question whether he really is mr zen
has he been has he been you know sort of
burying
this this disdain for good against
and and whatever he feels about matt
lafleur i don't know why
in the world you'd be upset about a guy
who going into sunday's game
had you 28 and seven over the last 35
games
when you were 15 19 and 1 over the
previous 35
i mean matt lafleur's been a pretty
great coach for that team
but again this is the way i feel about
events like this
everybody needs to calm down and
everybody needs to get away it's just
like what he said i think he's
absolutely right
i just need to get away and clear my
head as everyone does
you can't make a decision about the 2021
football season and who is your
quarterback with the guy who's got three
years left on his contract
on monday january 25th it's just it
makes no sense
anyway couple minutes left here with
peter king um so i got about two minutes
here peter
stafford uh what's the market for him
and is desean watson
going anywhere everything you hear is
that he wants to go here wants to go
there but he doesn't create a he doesn't
demand a trade even though whoever they
hire doesn't matter to him
i mean there's reports all over the map
here on watson
you know it's like i wrote in my column
today rich it is beyond
any reasonable expectation that if
i mean and i don't think josh mccown is
getting this job don't get me wrong i
think
they might hire him as a quarterback
coach or maybe even offensive
coordinator but
they know they can't hire joshua count
but if josh mccown anyway did get hired
you know that he would not take this job
without without
assurance that watson was going to be
his quarterback
and why do you think i mean
this is exactly why i think that you
don't make decisions
three months before the draft it's now
three months and four days before the
draft
i you just don't make decisions you you
calm down
and you tell uh you know you tell nick
casario
hey listen we got time to fix this let's
let's try
try to let cooler heads prevail and as
far as stafford goes
i think you'll have a good market you
should be able to get like
indianapolis got i think the 19th pick
in the draft or 21st
uh that seems like fair market to me for
a guy who's going to be 33 this year
and despite some great talent uh has
never won a playoff game in his life
um so that would seem to be fair
maybe somebody will offer more than that
i don't know peter you're the man
thanks again appreciate it let's talk
before the game and then after i'm not
gonna be shy calling you sounds good
rich take care the man that's peter king
i was on his podcast check it out
where all podcasts can be acquired